so this is one of our glove boxes yeah
so if you just look to the the right in
the glove box you'll see then we've got
these airlocks and basically what you do
is you put whatever is you want to take
into the box in there and then you
evacuate it and then you refill it with
dry oxygen free nitrogen so then you can
take compounds which react with air and
moisture into the box safely and store
them so this is a bit like what you see
pictures of in the nuclear industry when
you've got people handling things
okay so next up is uranium here which is
my favourite actinide it's the one I
handle in the lab it's also the
boogeyman of the periodic table I think
soon as you say uranium to people people
start going not true about that this is
the boogeyman this is uranium turnings
see they have a sort of dual appearance
because when they're cleaned up they're
really very reactive and there are
oxygen extremely quickly but if you ask
to treat them with concentrated nitric
acid you get really beautiful gleaming
surfaces but it doesn't hang around very
long
uranium is the basis of much of nuclear
power and it exists in two isotopes
that's two atoms of different weight
there's uranium-238 which is the most
abundant one and the other uranium-235
which is the one which when you're
radiated with neutrons will split in
half and release nuclear energy and a
lot of work has been done or was done
during the Second World War on the
separation of these isotopes of uranium
and including the construction of the
biggest mass spectrometers that had ever
been made
and fortunately the separation of
uranium isotopes is really very
difficult which is why it is only very
large and rich countries have been able
to afford to make nuclear weapons this
is just oil sat on the top so just like
we had to have oil to protect the
potassium we also need oil to protect
the uranium turnings if you really
finely divided uranium turnings there
pyrophoric which means they burst into
flames in the air just spontaneously but
it's actually a really interesting
element to deal with it's got a wide
variety of oxidation states and if you
use it in its depleted form it's
actually relatively safe to handle in
the laboratory now depleted material
only contains a very small quantity of
fissile uranium which is used in bombs
and nuclear reactors about 0.2 of a
percent it actually means that the
problem with handling depleted
is not the radioactivity although you
have to make provision for this the real
problem is it's highly poisonous and
about half a gram would kill you in a
very short period of time because it
attacks your liver very effectively this
is uranium tetrachloride
solvent-free it's a nice free-flowing
emerald green powder and if you dissolve
this up it softens like thf you get
beautiful green solutions from it
there's another form of uranium
so this is you and I'll dichloride
which has got two organic molecules
coordinated to it as well that's this
beautiful yellow color
so once you've removed the uranium-235
you're still left with very large amount
ninety-nine point more than 99% of the
mass of your original uranium is
uranium-238 in which you have removed
most but not all of the uranium-235 and
this is so-called depleted uranium which
is some of the densest material you can
get and so it is used where you want
something very heavy that's not too
large so for example it's used in the
counterweights that people put in
aeroplanes in liners in large aeroplanes
to balance the plane because you can use
of it takes up only a small volume of
space we have to keep it safe and secure
in a safe and we have to fill out huge
amounts of paperwork many a forest has
been chopped down for this paperwork I'm
sure but it's all very important because
you have to be certain that when you're
handling you and depleted uranium
compounds that you're not going to end
up poisoning anybody and you're not
going to end up going radioactive
compounds all over the place so we have
logbooks and we have to record how much
we use and when and how we dispose of it
we have detectors which we have to sweep
the lab well a lot of people usually
start off with I imagine you glow in the
dark which if I could do that I'd have
passed away a long time before that
point yeah it's the boogeyman thing
again a lot of people are quite sort of
surprised and you know so shocked to
hear that you're you're handling this
stuff but actually it's just like most
of the chemicals in the periodic table
and once you get past the boogeyman
image of it it's actually a very
interesting element to work with most
metal or metal elements do look like
this it's just that the number of
electrons they've got the number of
electrons they can take or they get rid
of is what defines their chemistry
and is that not dangerous but you know
uranium has this reputation being so
dangerous that you know putting us in
danger by holding out there no this is
depleted uranium so that's about not
0.2% of this is what you become to
consider fissile the rest of it is not
radioactive so it's all quite toxic but
you'd have your work cut out to eat this
stuff because it's extremely hard